look guys i'm still gonna watch it the
snyder cup movie is supposedly
uh i think according to zack snyder from
the vero app his new favorite app
it is going to be a four hour movie now
versus being a
mini series i have some some thoughts
about this
i'm obviously a supporter of the snyder
cut we both are very much looking
forward to it i was planning on reacting
to the mini series as well it's gonna be
really hard to cut down a four-hour
reaction i'll tell you that
ten minutes sit there for four hours oh
boy
backwards you're ready for a four pound
that's that's the only reason i don't
want it to be a four hour movie
reactions themselves will be a mini
series
we'll just break it up it'll have to be
there's some good things about this
and some bad and some things that i
think could be bad for me i don't want
to say they're
definitively bad i do have some thoughts
and i i did want to share them before
talking about some spider-man 3 photos
it was always supposed to be a movie to
begin with
the original vision was not to be a mini
miniseries it was supposed to be a film
that you experience in the theaters
and then here to make it a four hour
movie is essentially getting
the version of zack snyder being able to
complete justice league being told to
trim down justice league that goes out
in the theaters then we get the extended
cut of justice league
which would be this version right here
you know the extended director's cut
when everyone's like man those extended
directors cuts of zack snyder's are
always so much better
and that's what this four hour version
would be you guys follow me on that do
you follow me on that trajectory
there so yeah yeah i think i'd get you
if there was no joss whedon involvement
he was able to do whatever necessary
reshoots he needed to do then they were
like all right it's still a little too
long
trim it down then they put it out and
then we get the extended cut and it
would be this one
that to me is like okay this feels like
the original vision then even though
he's been doing a little bit of minor
reshoots here and there throwing the
joker in there yada yada it still feels
like this is the original way it's meant
to be viewed the thing that
had me kind of curious about it being a
miniseries presented itself with its own
obstacles that
i was very baffled by too you know when
people watch a good season in television
say like breaking bad for example
and they go man it's like watching a
really long movie it's like watching a
really long movie i'd say the
feeling of that is valid i'd say the
feeling that it feels that way
is very true but it's not in a hundred
percent true
because each episode still needs to
stand on its own
as a complete thing and it needs to end
in a way each episode needs to have an
ending that makes you want to come back
for next week
i think if you just cut up a four-hour
movie without definitive
solid cliffhangers that make you want to
tune in next week or even if you're
binging it because i think the plan was
to release it week by week but if they
were even
release it as just you know all
available right now which i don't think
they would have done
you still need to have good cliffhangers
then that involves tweaking the snyder
cut
then that involves changing up structure
because you need to make sure that each
episode feels
complete because i think we actually run
into this argument with
not like it's i don't think it's the
majority of fans per show but i've even
heard it with wanda vision lately
i heard it with the first two episodes
of the mandalorian man
where's the show going what's taking
this solana and everyone's like just
wait to
wait for all the episodes to come out
story's not done that's how these work
and i think for the snyder cut it would
definitely present itself with that
discussion
if you have a four-part mini series and
the
episodes don't end in a way that feel
like i want to come back next week
because of the fact that it wasn't meant
to be a mini series to begin with
so you'd have to structure it a little
different i don't know if it naturally
presented it that the way
i think there's a major difference
between a season of television
feeling like a big movie versus cutting
up a movie into several chunks
making episodes feel incomplete you know
yeah i mean that's actually how i
watched the extended cut of batman v
superman and while i did find that every
45-50 minutes you could sort of make
your own little cut
point and it would you know make for a
coherent episode but
that you know has something after it it
does make me wonder because yeah also
this is a very niche even though zack
snyder has proven himself to have a very
dedicated fan base part of me wonders
too if maybe delivering it all in one
chunk is a better case for the movie
because
somebody taps into the first installment
decides it's not
for them or whatever they might not come
back whereas if it's just one big chunk
you might have people
willing to sit it out and see how this
all culminates in one big long
go or something like that you know
that's fair but then i think that also
opens the door for the bad
side of things which is i think less
people will
watch it now it's a four hour move it's
four hours that makes no difference
for me for you for a lot of you guys
for snyder cut fans when a t is like
throwing down an investment in this
in my mind i'm thinking most people are
not going to want to watch a four
hour movie i just don't think most
people are going to want to do i mean
remember the irishman came out and that
was like a three and a half hour film
like granted justice league in terms of
it being like
a film with action scenes and stuff
should be more exciting
as opposed to a three and a half hour
straight drama
of a bunch of like uh old actors
i mean once you pass the three hour mark
you just immediately start getting
people
general mass audiences not just film
lovers
i know there's going to be some people
already who come out there and go well
the snyder cut's not meant for everyone
this undercut's not meant for all those
people
who um don't care about the snyder cut
movement i mean
that's fair it got to the point where
it's at because of the hardcore fans so
the hardcore fans will be undoubtedly
satisfied with the four-hour version and
i think they might even want more than a
four-hour version right now
i i think in terms of the future of zack
snyder films
with dc eu which i know there's been
back and forth about like
is he really done is he really not done
i feel like
less people will watch it streaming
numbers don't often
release what their viewership is on it
so they could come out and say this film
was a hit or didn't really perform as
well or something but at the same time
they're also releasing godzilla versus
kong in march now and i don't know if
that's an implication of anything
i don't know if that means that oh we
don't really have faith in
the snyder cut as much as we once did so
let's put out godzilla versus kong in
the same month as well
now or are they just trying to create
some big momentous streak because we'll
have two great big things on our hands
your mind can go either direction on
this thing yeah i'm sorry no i'm sorry
and and then i'll just
end it with saying that i think that
with the snyder cut i want more people
to watch this
i think it would be it make it more of
an event
type of thing if more people did watch
and i just think
less people other than the hardcore fans
or the compa fans or even the ones who
are super cynical that want to check it
out
i think if you're someone who's kind of
just a casual viewer you might just be
like it's four hours i don't watch that
yeah it really solidifies just how niche
it is and i have to imagine that they
didn't spend
70 million extra dollars on this only
for the die hard zack snyder fans they
probably did that hoping to cast a wider
net and that's
the one thing that keeps me coming back
to that whole cul-de-sac comment they
made about the snyder cut i feel like if
they had
combined this with the godzilla release
and kept it a mini series
that to me would say we want hbo max to
bring in so many more people we're gonna
double up whereas this
making it just one chunk of a movie yeah
i think you're right it sort of does
take down the event status and it takes
down the reach a little bit and so then
it makes it almost feel like they are
perhaps trying to make up for this or
something because also
ray fisher controversy has only gotten
louder in the past couple weeks and i
have to imagine that that's
affecting whatever is going on with the
film as well whether
you know zack snyder likes that or not
you know i just think that even if
you're
gonna release the mini series hbo max
could have experimented with all right
you know this is an original hbo max
exclusive
let's make it a mini series format let's
put it all out at once i think you might
i think you would get more people to
watch this yeah
yeah i think you would get more people
to watch your four-hour mini series the
less
work people have to do
when they don't have to make the
decision of is this a good time to pause
it
yeah exactly if you could cut it up into
chunks they're easily discernible then
you
also get the people who will be like
okay well i'll try out 45 minutes
of this in a place yeah that is
designated to stop so it won't leave me
with
a million confusion and i weirdly feel
like
as people constantly [ __ ] about oh it's
three to four hour movie but then
they'll
binge watch a series in a day for like
eight hours
and so i weirdly feel like if you put it
in a mini series format and you just
release it all at once
absolutely you're actually more likely
to get people to watch the whole
thing yeah on that day
really wonder if behind the scenes they
have really turned around on the
business side like the at t w b
side if they have really kind of pulled
out again on this
because it seemed like up until this
news it was pretty gung-ho
it's pretty much like let's boost this
yeah you can and now yeah i'm not sure
i don't know guys i mean we're gonna
watch it anyway i just wanted to do the
best it can do that's it that's all i
want that's all i want this video is not
an attack video this video is not a
drama video it's just a
slight concern yeah especially if
there's such a big deal out of it it's
being a mini series the dc
fandom like you know they made a big
announcement about it so it is kind of
interesting also
there are just not many details about
why this change you know
well guys are you for it do you want it
to be a four-hour mini series do you
want it to be a four-hour movie
does not really make a difference to you
leave your thoughts down below subscribe
click that notification bell hit that
like button
catch you guys soon